thanksgiving is a wonderful holiday it's
my favorite except for christmas and
easter which of course
have a special dignity this year's
thanksgiving is going to be
especially great and the reason is it
comes amidst trouble
there's trouble all over the place but
you know here we are
i'm in this chapel on this beautiful
campus the campus is
healthy happy partly disrupted
of which we complain and then the
complaints
actually remind us why we're here and
that helps us value that
the nation is in a terrible crisis we
don't know how long it's going to go on
we don't know what's going to happen
when it's over we are like the pilgrims
they came across the ocean didn't know
what they'd find
nobody had ever seen it first whether
they starved to death most of them
everybody got sick and then they got
through it
and then they had a pretty good summer
and there was a harvest
and of course that means food and they
stopped and they said thanks
they joined with their neighbors and so
they had a moment of peace
and they were grateful for that moment
you see their troubles reminded them
of their blessings which are inestimable
that's a word that occurs in the
beginning of the college's
founding document we have inestimable
blessings
we get to do this work all of us do each
of us has a work to do
to get to do that work that is the
hallmark of a free country
so of course we have to fight for our
freedom but that is part of the work
and we get to do that work too in a way
these troubles are good for us
they teach us they remind us what to
strive for
the old literature about suffering
is full of that reflection and is
redeemed by that reflection
and that is a tremendous thing to
remember and thanksgiving is the
time to remember it born for the purpose
of remembering it we will say our
prayers and thanks
this year in thanksgiving with special
intensity
we will pray for you too happy
thanksgiving
you